hey guys how's it going happy Veda uh so
ah do you guys see what I see it's a
freaking mess I just shot some photos
for something you could actually see it
on the floor I don't know it doesn't
matter
it'll be announced soon but I'm really
excited about it I don't have to
probably get some professional photos
done because the it is so awkward trying
to take photos and do a photo shoot by
myself I'm wearing a lot of makeup right
now so I'm gonna go wash my face
finish packing because I'm gonna be off
to somewhere to meet my sisters it's
gonna be an overnight flight so I have
no idea when I'm gonna post this video
or when you're going to see it this room
back together
classroom
time to find a suitcase outside its 7:49
I'm off to the airport
let's roll Peter to the airport the time
is now 9:30 - and I thought I'd get like
a really nice healthy swedish fish
obviously these really fine red-eye
flights Cyrilla just load up on the
snacks so I'm probably gonna hate these
fish and hop on the plane and go to
sleep let me land at JFK then altitude
to meet my sisters that's the plan
link would you like some camo with your
KML Arlo do you think ammo bro
so at 7:32 a.m. made it to JFK New York
first stop is at Shake Shack obviously
to get some breakfast and then
it's true that gay down there
I'm so tired this poor child and the
poor parents it was screaming and crying
the entire flight and there's nothing
you could do
it was just following its eyes out and
it sounded like a pain alright it's
loaded 41 p.m. I made it really tired go
figure
I slept terrible the plane I'm hoping
this is brie and Jenna's bag they're
supposed to get into run 140 which is
right now but they were also served 20
minutes late early late earth I don't
know this music I can't concentrate I
see them I see them they don't see me
we're girls I feel for they are there
they are
you
you can let yourself be here no well
I've been here for a little while nobody
really ya know when I saw Southwest I
was like score I also just really prefer
live band
it's not I thought it was like it's real
yeah hello hello welcome welcome to the
suite yeah I'm not there because I
forgot her I'm spying you know I didn't
do anything but ask a real nice I said
excuse me um Beyonce we did enough
pretty good so how many really excited
he was so nice yeah it was if we
originally had like a king bed so all
three of us were gonna sleep in a game
okay but look so who wants to sleep with
me yeah we're good he said let me
upgrade Jeff this pulls out to bed as
well so we're ready I'm exhausted
whoa somebody's sipping guys I had one
freaking daiquiri and I'm hammered I'm
honestly okay but there I don't think
there was alcohol in here I think he was
a virgin oh they're back on dude
this is terrible wait I'm wasted my
favorite thing to do is good sense that
we go I'm wasted
guys happy Thursday Thursday it is oh my
god
I still haven't slept you just woke up
30 years ago
I'm sad seriously guys I plus you know
credit honestly all I want to do is go
to bed and eat and go to bed eat go to
bed
uh yeah I'm gonna end this vlog right
now because I don't I'm not coherent
right now I'm not in a good state oh
wait wait it I don't even that drunk I'm
just really tired so I'll see you guys
later I'm old enough to drink so don't
worry I'm an adult so you're gonna get
the surf or are you gonna get the turf I
had to explain to general surf and turf
was I was supposed to end my vlog but I
was surf or the turtle yeah it's surfing
the truth I guess like well I don't do
either I guess turf because I am like
dairy hey do you want the turf hey what
I'm once a turf sir guys
we go all summer now we just gotta
[Music]